[Music]
johnny depp is testifying in his
defamation lawsuit against his ex-wife
that's amber hurd telling a court in
virginia that he never abused her he
says she abused him
now this dispute has been going on for
years and he's suing her for 50 million
dollars heard wrote in the washington
post back in 2018 that she is a survivor
of domestic abuse her op-ed did not
mention debt by name but he claims that
it damaged his reputation and his acting
career and now hurt is counter suing him
for 100 million dollars carter evans has
the story
good afternoon mr depp
good afternoon
johnny depp was one of the world's
highest paid actors on tuesday he took
the witness stand to respond to
allegations of abuse from his ex-wife
amber hurd
never
did i myself
reach the point of
striking misheard in any way
nor have i ever struck
any woman
depp says hers allegations are lies and
accused her of physically abusing him
within a
year year and a half
she
had become this
another person almost
the actress married depp in 2015 filed
for divorce 15 months later and sought a
restraining order
in a 2018 washington post opinion piece
she recounted her experience with
violence and referred to herself as a
public figure representing domestic
abuse on the stand depp said the
allegations ruined his career her
accusations had
sort of permeated the industry and then
made its way through
media and social media
it just kept getting bigger and bigger
the trial comes almost two years after a
british court dismissed depp's libel
case against an english tabloid that
called him a wife beater
that judge ruled depp repeatedly
assaulted her and caused her to fear for
her life attorney mediator winter
wheeler i understand wanting people to
know
that you've been falsely accused um if
that is in fact the truth
but
even if he wins i don't necessarily
believe that changes his career path
good or bad amber heard has not yet
testified if he thought the washington
post essay was bad what's he going to
think of her testimony
oh exactly all the dirty laundry is
being aired and it is only going to get
nastier
as things go on before the trial heard
said in a statement i wrote about the
price women pay for speaking out against
men in power i continue to pay that
price
today depp is expected to take the stand
again this time for cross-examination
for cbs mornings i'm carter evans
boy it's very messy i'm watching and i
have to say it's tough to watch i think
for both of them yeah both of them are
accusing the other both have pictures of
the of abuse that they claim happen by
their spouse and it's just so tough to
see all your personal business spilled
out that way it's it's it's tough but
also i feel like they're they're looking
for it in some sense i mean everyone's
had a relationship where there's some
kind of problem and these people have
very deep pockets to air it all and and
hope the judge says you're right and
you're wrong
it's kind of a fantasy everyone has uh i
don't know if they're going to get there
or not in the end well she still hasn't
testified so we'll see she's going to
take this in it you know people close to
them both say that they each know how to
push each other's business
each other's buttons not business you
might not do that too but i meant to say
buttons that was a different stage
things have taken a turn since then
all right gail